The idea behind
Project Night was
that we all like to learn by
making things and tinkering.
And we wanted to
create a community
around tinkering at Harvard.
So every week, we host an event
in the Active Learning Labs
or in the Science Center where
students or staff or community
members from all
across campus can come
and hang out, build
stuff for fun.
We have pizza.
People work on
personal projects.
And every week,
we have a workshop
to do some sort of
quick hands-on projects
so that people who don't already
have their own design ideas
can still have an easy entry
point into the community.
So the hope is
both to have people
kind of in the space learning
by building with tools
and experimenting
with engineering
but also to be an
open environment where
anyone can come and feel safe
and try out those new things.
One of the big benefits
of the whole project
was that we did work together
and saw each other for a couple
of years on a weekly basis.
Well, it started to get
really comfortable to go
over and share other
people's shop space.
I started to expand
where I thought I
was at home in the university.
And we shared a lot of things
like shop safety practices
and training practices that
I think have benefited--
certainly benefited us.
I think it's also helped
with collaboration.
So, for instance, we have a
tool that they don't have,
or they have a
tool we don't have.
It's made it a lot
easier to be like, hey,
can we borrow that for the day?
Or you have expertise
in this thing.
Can you help out
with this one class
that we don't have expertise in?
Yeah, or there's a
couple of classes
that are totally
outside of this project
that we've gone to them
for help on since they've
got a lot of expertise in
hands-on demonstrations.
And it's been super
helpful outside
of this project in terms of
the regular academic stuff we
support as well.
And in general expanding of
Harvard community, like Daniel
said, has been great.
And likewise, we have sent a
lot of students down to you
to laser cut, to bend
saw, to do things--
Likewise for the shop bot.
--that aren't easy
to do in our labs.
It's a very big mix of people.
I think we originally
thought it was
going to be mostly
undergrads, but we actually
got a huge group the first year.
Especially, we got a huge
group of the master's
of design engineering.
Basically, the entire
cohort would come over
to Project Night.
That was a lot of fun.
So we had a good mix of
undergrads, master's students,
and then we had a few people
that have been coming regularly
that are within the greater
Harvard communities,
so some Ed school
students, some people--
We've got some staff.
--some staff.
A couple of staff people.
Yeah, we did a survey
at the end of last year.
And we're in the midst
of one right now also.
And I think I don't have
actual numbers right now.
But the general trend
was that I think
people felt benefits were really
good for learning skills that
were also applicable to classes,
particularly people who are
using shop stuff in classes.
We've gotten a lot of
people learning electronics
and basic circuitry.
And I think there were
a fair number of people
who said that Project Night
was helpful for not only skills
but also motivation
in their STEM classes.
So I think, overall, it's been
helpful for people outside
of fun also.
I think it's helped people with
their presence in the labs too,
because there's, at least
on the engineering side--
when we see students
around a lot,
they tend to be more
involved with the community
and more involved
with their courses.
And I think they do
better just because they
build that community.
So I think it's definitely
helped them on that front,
whether the students
realize it or not.
I think I've seen
a lot of things
at Harvard where
you start and you
have all this motivation
at the beginning,
and it's really exciting.
And then over time, it
just kind of peters off.
But this is still going strong.
And I think even
after the HILT grant,
I think we've convinced
people that it's still
an important aspect.
So I think it'll just
continue to happen.
Yeah, I think,
when we started, it
was a thing we were all
passionate about that
wasn't necessarily something
everyone was convinced
was worthwhile.
And I think people
have explicitly told
us that from the management side
that they see the value in it
and want to keep on
doing more making stuff,
and that's kind of
folded into regular plans
for what we do as a group
within the university.
And we've been doing these
weekly during the semesters
now for a year and a half.
And I think that's also
something that feels,
like you said.
Actually having it
happen consistently
has felt really nice.
And we've had people who've
come pretty much every week
for that year and a half.
Yeah, I think the thing
that I'm proud of is
that we managed to establish
a community of people
who do get together.
And there's definitely
a core group
that you see every Project
Night, people working
on projects that they're
just really excited
about and also
people just bouncing
back and forth between projects
and then helping others work.
Yeah, I think I'm
proud of the community.
Mhm.